ich begrüße heute abend den
bundeskanzler olaf scholz herr scholz
wir schauen in die ukraine russland hat
dieses land überfallen vor acht tagen
acht des krieges
russische jets bombardieren unablässig
die ukraine
auch zivile ziele wie ingo renk kiew
[Musik]
die ukraine verzweifelt und todesmutig
stemmen sich gegen die angreifer
[Musik]
in der zweitgrößten ukrainischen stadt
kg f sind gestern und heute mindestens
34 zivilisten getötet und dutzende
verletzt worden
laut ukrainischem generalstab setzten
sich russische truppen 20 kilometer vor
pier fest und errichten feldlager
das seien nur der anfang von dem was
wahrscheinlich kommen sagten sie herr
scholz vor zwei tagen was befürchten sie
umso länger der krieg dauert umso mehr
zerstörung wird er anrichten es wird
mehr menschenleben
kosten werden zivilisten sterben aber
das sollten wir nicht vergessen auch
viele soldatinnen und soldaten
das hat mich sehr beeindruckt ich war ja
in der ukraine vor einiger zeit und auch
in russland ich bin dort empfangen
worden von einem militär empfangen ich
habe kränze niedergelegt
an die zur erinnerung an die opfer des
krieges des deutschen krieges
und das waren alles ganz junge männer
die da vor mir standen meistens keine 20
jahre alt und die ziehen jetzt auch alle
in den krieg und sterben vielleicht in
großer zahl das ist das was wir immer
wissen müssen dass das immer schlimmer
wird umso länger der krieg dauert und es
dann nicht nur darum geht dass da
infrastrukturen zerstört werden sondern
eben menschenleben hoffnung träume
trifft ist auch die zivilbevölkerung was
glauben sie wielange erhält man das aus
wie lange werden wir bilder wie aus
aleppo oder holmes ertragen sie lassen
sich kaum und gar nicht ertragen und es
ganz klar zu sagen wir dürfen uns damit
auch nicht abfinden sondern müssen da
auch alles für unternehmen dass das
nicht dazu kommt deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass wir nicht aufgeben sondern
ununterbrochen all die verschiedenen
maßnahmen weiter verfolgen die wir auf
den weg gebracht haben um einerseits mit
sanktionen die werden umsetzen druck zu
machen und andererseits immer wieder
spielräume zu eröffnen für diplomatie
lassen sie uns vielleicht doch eine
sekunde noch mal in der ukraine bleiben
die menschen in diesen belagerten
städten die brauchen lebensmittel die
brauchen medikamente wie lange wird
humanitäre hilfe allein noch möglich
seiten glauben sie über korridore hat
man heute verhandelt sich angeblich auch
verständigt auf sie allerdings ohne eine
waffenruhe das heißt dass bomben geht
weiter das wird auch immer schwieriger
trotzdem bemühen wir uns das an
hilfsleistung zu organisieren das
möglich ist zusammen mit allen
verbündeten in der europäischen union
und der nato und vor allem vielen
bürgern und bürgern in all den ländern
die auch selber einen eigenen beitrag
leisten um zu unterstützen und bisher
gelingt es ganz gut die waren nicht nur
an die grenze und in die nähe der grenze
sondern auch über die grenze in die
ukraine zu bringen aber das wird sicher
nicht einfach
volume ii die lenski der ukrainische
präsident
ist auch ihre gesprächspartner wann
haben sie das letzte mal mit ihm
telefoniert diese woche am dienstag
ausführlich über die situation und wie
das sich weiterentwickeln wird und
natürlich auch über die frage was man
tun kann dass die gespräche zwischen
russland und der ukraine stattfinden und
nicht einfach aufhören und hatte sich
fortsetzung gegeben und das ist auch gut
so auch wenn da so viele bisher ja nicht
raus gekommen eines der wichtigsten
kriegsziele putins soll ja aber der tod
von wolfgang osinski sein das wird
berichtet und das ist natürlich eine der
sachen die sehr fruchtbar ist wenn man
sich vorstellt dass darüber gesprochen
wird dass vertreter der demokratie in
der ukraine mit verfolgung rechnen
müssen nach dem militärischen
krieg aber jetzt geht es ja erst mal
darum den krieg zu verhindern und darauf
hinzuweisen dass das schon nicht mehr so
weitergehen kann wir brauchen eine
waffenruhe wir brauchen auch eine
situation in der verhandelt wird und
sich am ende auch die russischen truppen
wieder zurückziehen so unrealistisch
dass gegenwärtig erscheint dürfen wir
nicht nachlassen das zu versuchen der
krieg ist längst da sie haben gesagt
herr scholz putin wird nicht gewinnen
geht es auch dann noch wenn die ukraine
zerstört ist und nicht mehr existiert
oder modifiziert ist
was jetzt passiert ist ja ein krieg
gegen das ukrainische volk der russische
präsident
vertritt die these dass es das gar nicht
gibt das war immer falsch die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine haben
sich für die demokratie und für ein
eigenständiges land entschieden dass sie
selber gestalten wollen und
das ist ja doch dass eine ergebnis
dieses furchtbaren einmarsches dass
jetzt tatsächlich offenbar ist es gibt
ein ukrainisches folgendes verteidigt
sich sogar mit seinen wenigen mitteln
wird putin auf sie wie jemand der
aufgibt wenn man ihn besonders unter
druck setzt immer nur immer kromm hat
heute telefoniert 90 minuten direkt und
er war empört und ernüchtert über den
vortrag den er sich von wladimir putin
angehört hat und er rechnet mit dem
schlimmsten
es ist wichtig dass wir uns nichts
vormachen das haben wir nicht getan ich
habe immer wieder darüber berichtet und
nicht nur ich dass all der aufmarsch der
um die ukraine stattgefunden hat
ausreicht um eine vollständige version
der ukraine zu beginn das gehalt für die
truppen entlang der
ukrainisch-russischen grenze für die
truppen in der in belarus und das galt
natürlich auch für die
schiffe die wir von der seeseite her
sehen konnten und all das musste uns
immer klar machen dass dies eine
mögliche entwicklung ist deshalb haben
wir uns ja so viel mühe gegeben auch im
vorfeld noch bis zuletzt zu versuchen
das zu verhindern ich bin ja selber auch
in moskau gewesen und habe lange mit
ihnen gesprochen über die situation aber
all die argumente die wir mittlerweile
öffentlich kennen und die auch vorher
schon überall schriftlich zu lesen waren
ja dann hört und darüber diskutiert und
da geht es dann eben ganz viel auch um
geschichte und die vorstellung wie das
einmal früher war aber das ist etwas was
wir ganz streng zurückweisen müssen wenn
wir jetzt alle anfänger anfangen in
europa in den geschichtsbüchern zu
blättern möglichst lange rückwärts und
uns anzuschauen wo früher einmal grenzen
waren dann gibt es eine zeit unendlich
vieler kriege das darf nicht sein wir
müssen zurück kehren zudem
grundsatz den wir nun seit fast 50
jahren in europa festgelegt haben mit
der schlussakte von helsinki dass die
territoriale integrität und die
souveränität von staaten nicht und frage
gestellt wann konnte man das wissen oder
auch lesen und hören von ihm dazu werden
wir noch kommen glauben sie herr scholz
dass putin die ukraine reichen wird
belarus hatte im grunde genommen noch
sehen sie eine gefahr für das baltikum
sehen sie eine gefahr für die republik
moldau
wird ihnen die ukraine erreichen wir
sollten jetzt erst mal nicht
sagen das ist jetzt notwendigerweise so
dass es alles so kommt wie das da
geplant ist darum ja auch versuchen wir
mit verhandlungen zu verhindern dass zum
beispiel steht er jetzt in dem ausmaß
bombardiert werden zerstört werden wie
wir das befürchten müssen das ist ja
doch jede anstrengung wert wie ich eben
schon gesagt habe und auch nicht noch
mal unterstreichen will und darum müssen
wir uns noch jeden tag bemühen umgekehrt
ist es so dass wir uns nichts vormachen
dürfen wenn verträge nichts mehr gelten
wenn das recht keine bedeutung hat
sondern gewalt und stärke grund genug
sind ein anderes land anzugreifen dann
müssen wir jedenfalls als verbündete in
der nato wie auch in deutschland stark
genug sein um zu sagen dass das nicht
funktionieren wird und genau das haben
wir in den letzten jahren gemacht das
machen wir auch jetzt wir haben zum
beispiel sehr viele
nato-truppen auch im wald gekommen
deutschland hat seine präsenz in midtown
verstärken wir beteiligen uns an dem rp
leasing in rumänien hier sind bereit
weitere
truppenverbände zu stationieren zum
beispiel in das locker partei und dann
anderen orten mit anderen zusammen zu
arbeiten und gleichzeitig haben wir ja
auch klar gesagt wir werden dafür sorge
tragen dass die bundeswehr im rahmen der
nato so stark ist wie sein muss damit es
uns niemand angreift wir reden über eine
zäsur für die welt herr bundeskanzler
wir reden über eine zäsur für europa und
über eine zeitenwende in deutschland und
schauen noch mal auf diese bilder der
geschichte
in der kalte krieg ist vorbei
2001 standing ovations für putin
russland führt seit zwei jahren krieg in
tschetschenien
am sonntag standing ovations und
umarmung des ukrainischen botschafters
deutschland vollzieht die kehrtwende
keine waffenexporte in die ukraine
wandel durch handel und der viel bemühte
kritische dialog
noch vor einer woche waren das die
leitplanken deutscher außen- und
sicherheitspolitik wir werden keine
waffen an die ukraine liefern das war
richtig und das bleibt auch richtig die
mehrheit der deutschen sieht das genauso
wie ich aus vorbei letzten sonntag
erklärt der kanzler das was richtig war
für falsch sie wissen haben wir gestern
entschieden dass deutschland der ukraine
waffen zur verteidigung des landes
liefern wird
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukt sind unsere partei
die bisher
eine kehrtwende fast aller parteien für
die spd aber geradezu ein austausch
ihrer dna das prinzip der abschreckung
ist zurück
kommt die 180 grad wende noch
rechtzeitig
der ukrainische außenminister sagt hätte
deutschland diese entscheidung früher
getroffen dann hätte es diesen krieg
nicht gegeben
es hätte all die toten männer frauen und
kinder nicht gegeben
hätten sie hätte deutschland mit einer
früheren entscheidung herr scholz diesen
krieg verhindern können und im übrigen
spricht ja schon dagegen was wir
nachlesen können in den historisierenden
texten des russischen präsidenten in der
ankündigung der gemacht hat übrigens
auch in all den gesprächen wiederholt
hat der zuletzt geführt hat mit
präsident makro mit mir und vielen
anderen und deshalb ist es richtig dass
wir aus dem datum des angriffs auf die
ukraine auch unsere entscheidung jetzt
ableiten ich habe gesagt dieser
donnerstag hat die situation in europa
verändert und ist eine zeitenwende
und deshalb ist es auch wichtig neue
entscheidungen zu treffen wie die die
ich gesagt habe aber ich will eins an
dieser stelle bevor wir uns über all
diese fragen sehr ausführlich
unterhalten noch mal deutlich machen ich
weiß ganz genau was in den köpfen ganz
viele hervorgeht viele eltern kriegen
fragen von ihren kindern ob jetzt krieg
kommt ich weiß von vielen älteren die
aufgewachsen sind noch mit den
erfahrungen des krieges des letzten
großen krieges und den zerstörungen die
damit verbunden gewesen sind und die
angst haben und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir besondere sind dass wir
entschlossen sind dass wir einen klaren
kurs verfolgen und genau darum geht es
bei dem was ich am sonntag im bundestag
angekündigt habe und was wir auch jetzt
machen wir kommen auch noch einmal dazu
dass wladimir putin ja sogar mit dem
atomaren knopf spielt und offensichtlich
eben auch menschen zusätzlich in angst
versetzen möchten aber bleiben wir
vielleicht noch mal bei dieser tatsache
schicken sie herr scholz diese waffen
jetzt aus überzeugung in die ukraine
oder um dankbarkeit ihrer verbündeten
zum die sie lange lange gebeten haben
nein das ist eine entscheidung die wir
getroffen haben werden sie auch anders
treffen können und die wir richtig
gefunden haben wegen des angriffs auf
die ukraine warum sind sie so lange
gezögert was gab den ausschlag es dann
doch zu tun 500 dinge flugabwehrraketen
1000 panzerfäuste und wie wir heute
wissen 2700 luftabwehrraketen die noch
aus ddr beständen sind warum haben sie
so lange gezögert den
anderes habe ich schon genannt und
wiederhole noch mal das ist der angriff
auf die ukraine und die antwort ist auch
sehr klar deutschland hat eine politik
die seit vielen vielen jahren
jahrzehnten darauf gerichtet dass nicht
waffen in krisengebiete zu liefern um
die eskalation dieser konflikte zu
verhindern das haben wir sehr konsequent
über viele jahre verfolgten das werden
wir sicher an vielen stellen auch
weiterhin tun aber nach dem angriff auf
die ukraine wäre es falsch dass jetzt
noch fortzusetzen an dieser stelle weil
wir ja jetzt nicht mehr verhindern
können dass es diesen krieg gibt es gibt
ihn und da darf man diejenigen die
unschuldig angegriffen worden sind nicht
alleine lassen was gab den ausschlag es
muss endlich was hat sie also sie sagen
der beginn dieses krieges hat sie
überzeugt die verbündeten sind
erleichtert die loben sie jetzt auch
aber hängen bleibt die deutschen haben
zu spät unterstützt und zu wenig nein
das sieht niemand so und ich kann mir
das auch aus vielen gesprächen
versichern wie sehr die haltung der
bundesregierung nicht nur verstanden
worden ist in der vergangenheit sondern
die haltung die ich jetzt hier mit
meiner rede zum ausdruck gebracht hat
unterstützt wird ja geradezu darauf
viele finden das ist genau das was sie
sich jetzt in dieser lage von
deutschland mitten in europa erwarten
ich will doch noch mal sagen
das ist
etwas was wir nicht übersehen dürfen
hier hat eine der supermächte der welt
eine nuklear hochgerüstete supermacht
entschieden an krieg gegen das
nachbarvolk zu führen übrigens das
größte land der erde
gegen das zweitgrößte flächenland
europas das ist wenn man im ausland auch
als europäisches land begreift nämlich
die ukraine und dieser krieg gegen ein
land mit 40 millionen einwohner mehr als
40 millionen einwohnern das ist schon
eine ganz dramatische veränderung auch
deshalb weil es eben dafür gar keinen
grund gibt den man akzeptieren kann
russland nicht bedroht worden ist nicht
von der ukraine
aber natürlich auch nicht von der nato
zum nächsten leichte und trotzdem sagt
vizekanzler robert habeck heute die
entscheidung nicht heute entschuldigung
sagte er vor vier tagen die entscheidung
ist richtig aber ob sie gut ist das weiß
heute keiner was kann er damit meinen ob
sie gut ist oder nicht gut ist
robert habeck hat einfach zum ausdruck
bringen wollen dass das jetzt eine sehr
weitreichende sehr schwere entscheidung
ist die er unterstützt ich glaube die
allermeisten in deutschland die
allermeisten im deutschen bundestag die
parteien die die regierung tragen aber
auch zum beispiel die große
oppositionspartei cdu csu
aber das ist trotzdem dass ich trotzdem
eine entscheidung ist die eben
fällt in einer situation in der es
schwer ist den weiteren gang der dinge
vorher zu sagen ich aber sagen ich bin
ganz sicher dass es die richtigen
entscheidungen sind die wir jetzt
getroffen haben und dass wir sie auch zu
recht umsetzen sind sie überzeugt noch
mal die frage dass diese waffen wirklich
freiheit und frieden bringen sie haben
1983 als mittel junger mann auch auf dem
bonner hofgarten gestanden und gegen die
pershing demonstriert sind sie überzeugt
dass diese waffen gut sind oder richtig
sind und man weiß einfach noch nicht ob
sie wirklich gut sind und frieden
bringen ich halte die
waffen für richtig wenn man jemanden der
sie bedroht ist nicht alleine lassen
darf und das ist eine entscheidung die
ich nicht einfach nur nebenbei getroffen
und sie spielen auf meine aus meiner
heutigen perspektive jugend an als mitte
20 jähriger wo ich sogar mit organisiert
habe die friedenskundgebung die
seinerzeit stattgefunden haben aber ich
bin ausdrücklich sagen gerade vor diesem
hintergrund halte ich diese entscheidung
für richtig ist all das was wir erleben
er scholz in der ukraine nicht auch ein
offenbarungseid
von sozialdemokratischer oder deutscher
russlands politik ihr parteivorsitzenden
lars klingbeil sagt wandel durch
annäherung das war offensichtlich falsch
wir müssen ich zitiere einen
abschreckenden umgang mit autoritären
staaten wie china und russland finden
ist dieses konzept von brandt und scheel
gescheitert wandel durch annäherung ist
die despoten eigentlich stark gemacht
nein es ist nicht gescheitert das hat
ermöglicht die deutsche einheit die
überwindung der teilung europas das hat
eher möglich dass in vielen ländern
europas die demokratie sich durchgesetzt
hat dass wir einen vereint sind als
demokratin und rechts staaten in der
europäischen union 27 länder viele
andere sind auch auf diesen pfad
gegangen die das vorher nicht so
entscheiden konnten dh das konzept war
richtig und hat auch einen großen erfolg
eine große veränderung in europa mit
sich gebracht und trotzdem bleibt es ja
richtig dass man
darauf hinweist dass wenn ein land sagt
verträge sind gut und schön aber ich bin
ja stärker und ich setze mich über diese
hinweg dass das bedeutet dass wir damit
uns auseinandersetzen müssen und dass
wir nicht so tun dürfen als ob wir das
nicht wissen und darum ist es eben
richtig zu sagen wir wollen weiter alles
tun für diplomatische kanäle für
gespräche für den versuch eine
verständigung in dem konkreten ukraine
konflikt und sicher auf dauer auch
darüber hinaus aber es bleibt ebenfalls
eben richtig auf eigene stärke zu setzen
damit man aus der heraus eine
verhandlung führen kann genau und wann
haben wir das gemerkt wenn haben
sozialdemokraten gemerkt dass es gut ist
für den frieden sich einzusetzen
diplomatisch einzusetzen aber vielleicht
auch schlau ist parallel dazu sich
militärisch zu rüsten die
sozialdemokraten könnte man sagen haben
sich geirrt haben sie sich nur geirrt
oder kommt mit dem namen gerhard
schröder herr scholz auch noch
korrumpierbarkeit hin zu geben und damit
eine ganz andere kategorie die auch an
ihrem image und an ihrer glaubwürdigkeit
markt
zunächst mal haben sich die
sozialdemokraten gar nicht gehört
sondern mit sehr erfolgreichen
verteidigungsministern dafür gesorgt
dass deutschland eine über jahre jahre
eine gut gerüstete armee hatte ich einen
georg leber an helmut schmidt an hans
appel ich erinnere rudolf scharping und
peter struck die das alle sehr sehr
hervorragend gemacht haben und deshalb
ist das keine neue erkenntnis wir haben
lange zeit das verteidigungsministerium
geführt wo deutschland übrigens über
drei prozent seines sozialprodukts für
verteidigung ausgegeben hat und wir
haben eine zeit der sparsamkeit dass die
verteidigung betrifft erlebt die
begonnen hat mit einem csu
verteidigungsminister gibt es einen
fraktionschef mütze nicht der noch davon
träumte dass man vielleicht die nato
auflösen kann
man rolf mützenich ist ein der festen
überzeugung dass die nato zu unserer
sicherheit und stabilität dazu gehört
und im übrigen kann ich ihnen versichern
dass er das was ich im bundestag
vorgestellt habe unterstützt jeden tag
übrigens in diesen debatten und teilen
wir diese situation
ist es in dieser situation genauso
wichtig wie mir dass wir genau das
richtige tun das was jetzt zu tun ist
noch mal die frage zu gerhard schröder
die kann man ihnen nicht ersparen wie
sehr
nochmal schadet der spd genau diese
vorwurf der vorwurf das ist einen
ehemaligen kanzler aus ihren reihen gibt
der korrumpierbar ist
ich finde es nicht richtig dass gerd
schröder diese ämter wahrnimmt und ich
glaube auch dass es richtig wäre er
würde sie niederlegen ob es der spd
schadet wo jeder weiß dass wir damit
nicht einverstanden sind das weiß ich
nicht das hoffe ich nicht und das glaube
ich auch nicht aber an meinen rat an
gerd schröder ist doch sich aus diesen
ämtern zurückzuziehen ist ein solches
handeln eines ehemaligen bundeskanzler
seine privatsache nein es gibt überhaupt
keine private angelegenheit wenn man ein
öffentliches amt hat die dicht auch im
hinblick auf das öffentliche amt mit
betrachtet werden muss da gibt es dinge
die sind privat und die gehen auch
niemanden was an aber immer muss man
sich rechtfertigen können vor dem
hintergrund der aufgabe die man hat vor
der öffentlichkeit in der demokratie und
dem start und diese verpflichtung endet
nicht wenn man die ämter nicht mehr
ausübt sondern sie geht auch weiter muss
man gerd schröder seinen apparat
streichen
ich glaube dass wir regelungen brauchen
die für alle gleich sind das will ich
dazu sagen aber natürlich wird sich der
deutsche bundestag auch mit dieser frage
auseinandersetzen jedenfalls die
bundestagsmitarbeiter nicht dafür
einzusetzen solche aufgaben wahrzunehmen
die sich aus privatwirtschaftlichen
tätig hätten ergeben das ist eine klare
aussage die stadt hannover will ihm die
ehrenbürgerschaft aberkennen die uhr
tickt sagt lars klingbeil was glauben
sie sie kennen ihn gut wie lange würde
waren wir da noch brauchen ich hoffe
dass all die vielen freunde der
unverändert hat und die ihn ansprechen
ihn überzeugen können dass er seine über
schalten scheidung aus der vergangenheit
überdenkt und das sage ich auch weil ich
ja mit ihm gemeinsam
gut zusammengearbeitet habe in der zeit
seiner aktiven politik und deshalb wäre
es mir auch sehr wichtig dass er diese
entscheiden trifft die vorgeschichte ist
lang putin hat seinen krieg schon vor
jahren erklärt und 2014 gegen die ost
ukraine hier auch geführt und
deutschland hat sowohl im jahre 2008 als
auch 2014 immer eine besondere rolle
gespielt
den staaten liegen noch die toten eher
unübersichtlich und widersprüchlich
seien 1400 menschen dabei ums leben neue
kämpfe 2008 russischer blitzkrieg in
georgien es geht um die von moskau
kontrollierte teilrepublik abchasien
beide seiten provozieren deutsche
politik setzt auf deeskalation im
kaukasus ein entschiedenes nein gegen
all diejenigen die anleihen nehmen
wollen an rezepten des kalten krieges
das kann und darf nicht sein die usa
werben für den nato-beitritt der ukraine
die regierung merkel verhindert dass
[Musik]
2014 im märz annektiert putin die krim
im donbass kämpfen separatisten gegen
die ukrainische armee verdeckte
militärische unterstützung kommt aus
moskau
aus berlin kommen wieder nur mahnungen
ohne konsequenzen
die verletzung der territorialen
integrität in europa und wenn dieses
prinzip von uns akzeptiert wird dann
haben wir in ganz europa ein problem es
blieb dem deutschen nein zur nato
beitritt und waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine
noch mal die frage herr scholz hätte man
nicht über den frieden reden können und
sich parallel
militärisch vorbereiten können und
müssen und warum ist das nicht passiert
ist weiß nicht nur ihre partei sondern
ja auch unter angela merkel der fall
warum wollte man das nicht hören sie
haben das vorhin schon angesprochen 2008
hatte es erwähnen 2014 hat er sogar
krieg geführt gegen die ukraine die
aufsätze sind erwähnt besonders der aus
dem letzten jahr wo er der ukraine auch
ein selbstbestimmungsrecht abspricht und
von kleinen russland spricht glaube ich
aber das war jetzt jüngere geschichte
man hätte sehen und wissen können dass
putin nicht akzeptiert dass die ukraine
nicht mehr russische einfluss ist
einflussgebiete das hätte man nicht nur
sehen können das ist gesehen worden will
ich auch sagen das gilt für frau merkel
die dort im bild war oder auch dem
damaligen außenminister und jetzigen
bundespräsidenten beide haben das sehr
genau gesehen und trotzdem war es
richtig in der verantwortung um die
friedensordnung in europa die richtigen
entscheidungen zu treffen und das will
ich jetzt hier an dieser stelle noch
einmal ganz klar sagen es geht auch bei
allem was wir machen darum zu verhindern
dass es zu einer direkten konfrontation
zwischen der nato und russland kommt
präsident biden hat sehr eindringlich
vor einem solchen szenario gewarnt und
deshalb wird es jetzt auch keine
entscheidungen geben die dazu führen
dass nato-staaten sich militärisch in
dieser auseinandersetzung
beteiligen das würde eine dramatische
eskalation
dieser schwierigen lage in der ukraine
mit sich bringen das würde große
gefahren mit sich bringen und deshalb
wäre es keine verantwortliche politik
das jetzt zu machen und es wäre auch zu
früheren zeitpunkten keine
verantwortliche politik gewesen putin
fordert eine neutrale ukraine eine
entmilitarisierte ukraine all das was er
ansonsten der regierung noch vorwirft
ist hinlänglich bekannt
wie realistisch glauben sie denn war das
jemals also neutral eine pufferzone eine
finlandia sierte ukraine hatte es diesen
plan jemals gegeben in seinem kopf
glauben sie und wollte er nicht
eigentlich eine routinierte ukraine und
herrn janukowitsch wieder einsetzen ein
marionettenregime na ja sie haben schon
einige seiner historischen texte
angesprochen hat sich zu dem
zusammenhang zwischen russlands
geschichte und weißrussland und klein
russland via ukraine bezeichnet hatte
geäußert er hat über fehlentscheidungen
der
kommunistisch bolschewistischen partei
1922 gebrochen und verschiedenes andere
angeführt und das alles lag auf dem
tisch musste man wissen konnte man
wissen und wussten auch viele ich
jedenfalls habe mir darüber niemals eine
illusion gemacht ich glaube auch viele
andere nicht trotzdem bleibt es richtig
dass wir einmal ukraine nicht in die
nato aufgenommen haben georgien nicht in
die nato auf gelangt richtig und es auch
eine richtige entscheidung gewesen
damals gab es sehr sehr lange
verhandlungen in der nato über diese
frage und ich will ausdrücklich sagen
dass das ja auch jetzt ja gar nicht auf
der tagesordnung stand und steht das ist
übrigens etwas was mich wirklich
sehr bedrückt ich habe bewusst nicht nur
in einem zimmer wo keiner zuhört sondern
auch in der öffentlichkeit gesagt das
wissen wir doch alle dass die der
nato-beitritt der ukraine nicht andere
tagesordnung steht das hat der
amerikanische präsident auch zu
verstehen gegeben das hat der
französische präsident zu verstehen
gegeben das hat auch der
nato-generalsekretär letztlich
ausgedrückt mit dem zusatz dass wir
trotzdem natürlich nicht ausschließen
können dass länder sich demokratisch
entscheiden das zu wollen und nicht über
sie hinweg entscheiden können aber
angesichts dieser situation wäre es ja
richtig und auch völlig vernünftig
gewesen auch für russland das angebot
anzunehmen dass die usa und die nato
gemacht haben zum beispiel
fragen von
transparenz von truppen und
militärischen stärken zu reden und
wieder einzusteigen rüstungskontroll
verhandlungen seine sorge die auch
formuliert hat ist dass die nato geplant
hat in der ukraine raketen die auf
moskau berichtet sind zu stationieren
das ist in keinem fall
von irgendwem gewesen und natürlich
hätte man sich in solchen
rüstungskontrolle gespräch auch darauf
verständigen können dass das nicht
passieren soll und deshalb ist das jetzt
doch etwas sehr sehr bemerkenswertes das
obwohl alle ist klar ausgesprochen haben
dass dieser kriegsgrund nicht existiert
ist trotzdem ging fix grund gewesen dass
er befürchtet dass irgendwann mal
entferner zeit vielleicht doch die
ukraine in die nato
eintritt das heißt jetzt aber auch olaf
scholz das ist eine spd einen
bundeskanzler der sich immer viel auf
die guten gesprächskanäle nach moskau
eingebildet hat offensichtlich nicht nur
sein gehör nicht fand sondern jetzt auch
er mit emanuel makro redet und auf der
anderen seite auch der bundeskanzler
olaf scholz von wladimir putin belogen
wurde in diesem gespräch oder hat er
ihnen geantwortet auf ihre frage ob
jetzt eine offensive in kiew und in
rackith ansteht ich verrate kein
geheimnis wenn ich das wiederholen was
ich gleich im anschluss an das lange
gespräch mit präsident putin in der
gemeinsamen pressekonferenz klar gemacht
habe es hat eine solche aussage dass das
nicht passieren wird nicht gegeben es
heißt erklärung die er selber dann da
abgegeben hat auf die frage von
journalisten dass er das nicht vor hat
aber die aussage das wird nicht sein hat
niemand bekommen und deshalb war es für
alle klar dass das eine ernsthafte
gefahren eine ernsthafte bedrohung ist
was ja auch dazu geführt habe dass wir
uns wochen lang fast monatelang darum
bemüht haben uns auf diese situation
vorzubereiten damit wir glaubwürdig klar
sagen können wenn das passiert das die
beiden
angeblichen volksrepublik als teil
staaten anerkannt werden wenn das
passiert dass es zu einem militärischen
invasion der ukraine kommt dann wird das
auch mit sanktionen beantwortet werden
und diese wussten jetzt nicht alles
schnell neu entwickelt werden darüber
haben wir zusammen mit den usa hier
zusammen mit der europäischen union
lange verhandelt das so vorbereitet dass
jetzt ein einheitliches vorgehen möglich
ist innerhalb der nato innerhalb der
europäischen union mit großbritannien
mit kanada mit den usa mit japan mit
vielen anderen die sich noch anschließen
und die weltgemeinschaft auf das was da
passiert auch mit einer harten antwort
reagieren kann die übrigens ja schon
jetzt obwohl die meisten maßnahmen noch
gar nicht endgültig umgesetzt sind
massive auswirkungen hat die börsenkurse
in russland sind eingebrochen die
währung ist in größten schwierigkeiten
es wird das wirtschaftliche wachstum an
ganz vielen stellen beeinträchtigt sein
und das alles war angekündigt um genau
diese in version zu verhindern und
natürlich ist es richtig dass die
angekündigten hast du jetzt auch
umgesetzt werden und ihm offensichtlich
auch zornig machen nutzt ring 2 ist tot
das hat auch lange gebracht warum
glauben sie lebt nord stream 1 loch und
warum
bezieht der empörte westen weiter gas
und öl aus russland übrigens nicht nur
deutschland sondern auch die usa weil
wir es dringend brauchen und weil wir
nicht so schnell ersatz für das
russische gas finden wir haben sehr
präzise sanktionen beschlossen was den
finanzsektor betrifft was die
staatsfinanzierung was
unternehmensfinanzierung betrifft wir
haben sehr präzise sanktionen
beschlossen was den export von
hochtechnologischen gütern betrifft da
war haben wir uns besonders viel mühe
gegeben weil das nämlich die sind die
man nicht einfach woanders in der welt
einfach sich besorgen kann sondern wo es
unverändert ein großes einen großen
technologischen vorsprung
zum beispiel west europas nordamerikas
japans gibt in diesen fragen und wir
haben ganz besonders bemühen uns auch
gegeben sehr konkrete und
extraktion zu beschließen und da war
immer zu bedenken was das im übrigen
auch für auswirkungen bei uns selber hat
sie so zum beispiel dazu zählt zum
beispiel auch das natürlich ein großer
teil der europäischen länder auf öl gas
und kohle lieferungen aus russland
angewiesen auf baut er den eigenen
import strukturen vorgesehen hat das
gilt übrigens auch für die usa oder wir
aber nicht naiv sind haben wir
einerseits diese regelung getroffen aber
gleichzeitig auch uns sehr früh schon
vorbereitet für die situation dass das
dort auch schwierigkeiten geben könnte
deshalb wissen sie zum beispiel jetzt
auch aus meinen ankündigung aber dass
wir vorbereitet haben dass wir auch
anderswo gast eingekauft kaufen das
handeln gemacht und machen wir weiter
deshalb werden wir jetzt in großer
geschwindigkeit dafür sorgen dass es
auch andere technische möglichkeiten
gibt gas zu beziehen dass wir für die
nächsten jahre noch brauchen deshalb
werden wir lng terminals an der
norddeutschen küste errichten und
deshalb haben wir und das haben wir
nicht spontan entschieden sind
sorgfältig vorbereitet schon die ganze
zeit dieses jahres um angefangen im
letzten jahr darüber zu diskutieren
und deshalb haben wir sehr bewusst auch
noch einmal unterstrichen dass unsere
unabhängigkeit jeden tag größer wird mit
dem es uns gelingt die erneuerbaren in
der natur auszubauen auf diese importe
nicht mehr angewiesen sind robert habeck
sagt heute wir importieren weiter öl und
gas aus russland weil sonst ich zitiere
der soziale friede bei uns in gefahr ist
er schließt forderungen nach einem
embargo für russische energieimporte aus
nochmal nord stream eins gibt es nach
wie vor und über diese leitung die eben
auch um die ukraine herumgeht beziehen
auch wir weiter öl und gas damit halten
wir das system putin herr scholz am
laufen damit verdient er weiter geld
weiter gas öl und kohle aus russland
übrigens gibt es mehrere so gemeint hat
sich prozent 50 prozent und 37 glaube
ich ja genau also es ist nicht nur gas
ja ich habe gesagt das ist und
im hinblick auf das gas muss man sich
klar machen wir haben etwa 25 prozent
unserer energieversorgung die auf gas
beruht davon knapp die hälfte aus lang
wie sie eben hier auch berichtet haben
und deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
früh angefangen haben uns auf eine
schwierige situation vorzubereiten und
dass wir auch weitreichende
entscheidungen treffen die sich auf die
nahe zukunft richten um unsere eigene
unabhängigkeit zu erhöhen das ist genau
das was man jetzt tun muss um tun kann
und wir müssen uns da auch völlig einig
mit unseren europäischen nachbarländern
und den usa die mit uns das gemeinsam
als konzept entwickelt haben sie kennen
alle kritiken an dem projekt nord stream
2 noch bis zum dezember des jahres 21
haben sie von einer
privatwirtschaftlichen initiative
gesprochen tut ihnen das heute leid herr
scholz wenn sie sehen wie sehr es eben
auch einfach ein
strategisches fund genommen hat der
ukraine genommen hat da eben auch diese
leitung um die ukraine herum gegangen
wäre und ein direkter verbund nach
deutschland und in andere europäische
länder gebracht hätten noch mal dieses
lange beharren darauf dass ist eine
privatwirtschaftliche initiative tut
ihnen das heute leid das ist ein lange
verfolgtes projekt gewesen dass mehrere
bundesregierung mit vorangetrieben haben
was die ermöglichung betrifft und
ansonsten glaube ich machen sich einige
nicht klar wir beziehen gas aus norwegen
wir beziehen gas aus den niederlanden
beziehen gas aus russland und das kommt
über mehrere pipelines über die ukraine
über belarus und polen richtig aber
diesen wir darauf aus sie sehen über die
aussehen mit nord stream 1 und deshalb
ist das glaube ich auch etwas was in der
diskussion nicht jedem so ganz klar ist
es ging um die vierte pipeline wo es
drei schon gibt polen die usa andere
länder in der welt haben sie immer
darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass man putin
umso schwerer noch mit etwas drohen kann
wenn man eine solche pipeline baut noch
mal die frage war es zu spät nein es war
genau der richtige zeitpunkt übrigens
auch der angekündigte dann auch das habe
ich ja nach dem gespräch mit dem
russischen präsidenten öffentlich
wiederholt was auch in unserem gespräch
eine rolle gespielt hat russland musste
wissen dass wir diese entscheidung
treffen die dann notwendig ist und wir
wussten dass auch wir hatten uns völlig
darauf vorbereitet dass wenn es zu einem
angriffskrieg kommt wer das
genehmigungsverfahren zurückdrehen und
die
untersuchungen die dazu angestellt
worden sind ob die energiesicherheit
durch dieses projekt gefährdet es noch
mal neu aufrollen müssen wir schauen und
versuchen es wenigstens ein bisschen in
die zukunft holz die ukraine will
mitglied der eu werden georgien seit
heute und die republik moldau sind sie
dafür
die europäische union ist eine
gemeinschaft demokratischer
staatenbericht staatlichkeit demokratie
und marktwirtschaft als gemeinsame
prinzipien verfolgen
sozialstaatliche vorstellungen haben und
im übrigen eine ganze reihe von festen
regeln haben und dazu gehört zum
beispiel auch dass auf der tagesordnung
steht eine entscheidung über die frage
der westbalkan staaten und deren
aufnahme perspektiven darüber wird
sorgfältig und lange gesprochen sagen es
gibt weitere länder die interessen haben
aber wo man auch sehr klar sein muss
dass das natürlich ein land was lässt
dass das natürlich voraussetzungen hat
und deshalb ist das glaube ich jetzt
nicht die frage um die es gerade geht
wir müssen einen krieg verhindern wir
müssen nicht verhindern ist ja schon
gange wir müssen dafür sorgen dass er
nicht weiter eskaliert wir müssen alles
mögliche dafür tun dass eine gute
entwicklungsperspektive für die ukraine
dabei herauskommt und das land nicht
völlig zerstört wird und nicht millionen
menschen zu tode kommen unglaubliches
leid in diesem und sich über die
nächsten jahre und jahrzehnte
ausbreitet und das ist die aufgabe die
wir jetzt haben ursula von der leyen
sagte im laufe der zeit gehören sie
tatsächlich zu uns sie sind einer von
uns und wir wollen sie drin haben so
weit würden sie nicht gehen jetzt geht
es darum konkrete hilfe zu organisieren
und ich glaube dass die konkrete hilfe
die wir jetzt leisten auch alles das was
wir an diplomatischen bemühungen
unternehmen die aufgabe der stunde ist
wie die welt sich wenn wir das geschafft
haben sollten diesen krieg zu beenden
weiterentwickeln wird das werden wir
dann auch in dieser konkreten situation
besprechen erst mal wissen wie lange es
schon dauert für einige staaten die seit
langem eine aussicht haben dafür dass
man mit ihnen den prozess beginnt und
die das esslinger noch die
entscheidungen nicht bekommen haben er
will ich auch ausdrücklich an dieser
stelle noch mal daran erinnern manche
der entscheidung die im hinblick auf die
westbalkanstaaten in der vergangenheit
getroffen worden sind also das ehemalige
jugoslawien im wesentlichen sind völlig
unakzeptabel ich bin dafür dass wir
denjenigen die sich dort für die
europäische beitrittsperspektive so sehr
einsetzen endlich klare aussagen machen
und dann sind wir bei dem blick nach
vorn in bezug auf diesen krieg herr
scholz wer könnte in ihren augen eine
vermittlerrolle spielen kann dass israel
sein da waren sie gestern zu besuch kann
dass indien sein kann dass china sein
wird sie überhaupt noch gebraucht
auf alle fälle sind alle versuche zu
sprechen wichtig deshalb wird es auch
weiter gehen müssen auch ich werde nicht
aufhören
nicht nur mit der ukraine und dem
ukrainischen präsidenten zu sprechen
sondern eben auch mit dem russischen
präsidenten
da bin ich mir völlig einig mit emanuel
makro ich bin mir übrigens auch
eigentlich mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten wir dürfen nicht nachlassen
alles dafür zu versuchen dass es zu
einer friedlichen nein das kann man
nicht mehr sagen dass es zu einem ende
dieses krieges kommt und dass eine
andere perspektive eröffne fabrik
einwendern andere staaten sich dafür
auch einsetzen da ist das ein gutes
zeichen
und wenn es dann so ist das praktisch in
der den vereinten nationen fast alle
staaten dafür gestimmt haben dass dieser
krieg verurteilt wird dann ist das auch
ein gutes zeichen und alle müssen sich
bemühen alles was ihnen zur verfügung
steht einzusetzen um jetzt die
kampfhandlungen zu beenden und ein
ausweg aus dem krieg zu finden auch die
sanktionen helfen ja nicht der ukraine
in der jetzigen situation
diese sanktionen sollen das regime putin
bestrafen und sie bestrafen natürlich
auch die russen wann denken sie wird
putin zu gegen sanktionen greifen und in
seinem land das kriegsrecht fall
wir wissen dass nicht wir können das
nicht ermessen dann welche entscheidung
getroffen werden aber ich nehme sehr
wohl zur kenntnis dass es ziemlich viele
bürger mainburger russland es gibt die
mit der jetzigen entwicklung nicht
einverstanden sind und ich bin sehr
berührt davon dass einige das auch
öffentlich zeigen kundgebung
veranstalten bei der frau dann ja doch
einen ganz ganz anderen mut als es
hierzulande erforderlich ist herze
hierzulande erforderlich ist wenn man
auf eine kundgebung gehen will das
stimmt und sie hoffen also auf den mut
der russen weil nur die russen kotin
tatsächlich den garaus machen können
eine opposition die wir auch sehr lange
allein gelassen haben außer vielleicht
im fall wally und in der unterstützung
von menschenrechts-organisationen da
sollten wir ganz klar sein die
demokratie kann in den ländern der welt
muss von den muss von in den ländern der
welt von den bürgerinnen und bürgern
ausgehen regime change ist keine gute
perspektive und das ist auch etwas was
ich immer wieder klar gesagt habe wir
erwarten von russland das ist damit
umgehen kann das in seiner nachbarschaft
eine große gemeinschaft demokratischer
staaten in offener gesellschaften
existiert
meinungsunterschiede akzeptiert werden
in der wir unsere einheit auch durch
pluralismus gewinnen indem wir unsere
unterschiede zusammenführen so etwas das
die gemeinsame haltung dann des ganzen
landes wird aber das werden wir nicht
von außen in andere länder
exportieren können und dorthin
exchange aber was soll jetzt noch dieser
kompromiss sein der putin auf der einen
seite befriedigt beruhigt und auf der
anderen seite dafür sorgt dass die
ukraine weiter in ihrem land leben
dürfen was soll das für ein kompromiss
sein der da jetzt noch ausverhandelt
wird oder welche exit strategie wie
könnte das aussehen wer an dieser stelle
glaubt es gibt den einen knopf auf den
man drücken kann und dann sind die
probleme gelöst der hätte ihn uns früher
mal mitteilen sollen den gab es nicht
und gibt es auch jetzt nicht es gibt
jetzt nur beharrlichkeit
festigkeit in den eigenen grundsätzen
und die eigene klar und die feste
entschlossenheit nicht aufzuhören zu
versuchen verhandlungs strukturen zu
schaffen in denen dann nach einem
solchen konsens gesucht wird die
ausgangsposition sind sehr
unterschiedlich und es kann ja nicht
darauf hinauslaufen dass man einfach
alles akzeptiert was gefordert wird und
außerdem haben wir auch noch die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine und
der gewählte präsident da eine ganz
eigene meinung zu haben es geht ja um
sie und sie müssen das entscheiden was
wir hinkriegen müssen ist dass es wieder
gespräche gibt und dass der krieg zu
ende geht und dass wir auf der basis
einen ausweg finden das ist jetzt
gerade sehr gefährlich und jeden tag in
dem der krieg weiter geht wird er auch
dramatischer und wird es mehr opfer und
verletzte geben und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir diesen weg nicht
verlassen wie füllt man verhandlungen
oder redet mit jemandem der einen schon
so oft gelogen hat und worin soll dann
der kompromiss bestehen und welche
menschen kann man die bürger auferlegen
das auszuverhandeln auf all diese fragen
kann man jetzt schwer antworten das muss
man der fairness halber vielleicht auch
sagen aber für wie realistisch erachten
sie es überhaupt zu sagen wir erhalten
gesprächskontakte aufrecht wenn sie
ständig belogen werden
wichtig ist dass die ukraine teil jeder
verständigung ist und auch die gewählte
regierung
und dass das wie lange noch herr scholz
das muss man doch ganz ehrlich es dann
ganz ehrlich fragen und die antwort auf
diese frage ist ja dass wir das eben
ermöglichen wollen mit dem was sie tun
aber keiner von uns beiden die man sonst
auf der welt kann jetzt irgendetwas
machen dass das erzwingt denn das würde
ja bedeuten dass wir zu mitteln greifen
die wir ausschließen müssen um des
friedens willen und deshalb ist es ganz
ganz wichtig dass wir hier klar sind in
dem was wir machen und was wir nicht
machen dass wir aber das was wir machen
können tatsächlich tun und nicht nur
darüber eine million flüchtlinge haben
das land schon verlassen die europäische
union rechnet mit fünf millionen bis
sieben millionen vielleicht noch mehr
sagen die vereinten nationen wie wird
unsere unterstützung für polen aussehen
wie wird unsere unterstützung für ungarn
aussehen die haben jetzt die größten
zahl die größte zahl aufgenommen wir
haben angeboten zu helfen europa
insgesamt und das wird auch so sein dass
jeder darauf rechnen kann dass wir das
machen und das gilt ja überhaupt
insgesamt was braucht migrationsbewegung
nach europa betrifft wenn jeder immer
denkt wenn er nicht daran es haben die
anderen ein problem dann wird nie die
gemeinschaft sagen euer problem ist auch
unser problem das sollten wir aber in
diesem fall sagen das heißt wir werden
als europäische union gemeinsam handeln
und das wird auch gerade intensiv
vorbereitet was zb nutzung von
rechtlichen regelungen betrifft die wir
im zusamtal wir krieg gefunden haben und
die schnelle und unbürokratische
verfahren ermöglichen er und dass auch
alle länder glaube ich eine große
aufnahmebereitschaft haben das ist er
stellte das alleine schultern müssen und
was jetzt an herausforderungen auf die
zukunft gestern besaßen polen und die
ungarn noch auf der anklagebank und
heute helfen sie in dieser form den
menschen sie erstaunt angenehm
überrascht erfreut sind sie darüber
ich bin überhaupt nicht erstaunt wir
gehören zusammen in der europäischen
union natürlich haben wir fragen die wir
miteinander zu diskutieren haben aber
auch da gibt es ja jeden versuch die
aufzulösen und ich habe sogar unabhängig
von dieser krise an verschiedenen
stellen gute ansätze gefunden eine
lösung zu erarbeiten für nur daran
erinnern dass der polnische präsident
ein eigenes gesetzesvorhaben an das
polnische brasilien parlament
weitergeleitet hat um zb in der
rechtsfrage eine lösung zu finden die
für die europäische union und für polen
funktioniert eine gute lösung ist dass
darüber wird konkret diskutiert wie das
funktioniert und deshalb will ich immer
sagen an der tatsache dass die völker
die zusammengekommen sind in der
europäischen union sich auch deshalb
verein weil sie gemeinsame vorstellungen
haben von demokratie von offenheit der
gesellschaft von rechtsstaatlichkeit
ist ja nicht zu rütteln an der ist nicht
zu rütteln sie haben gesprochen
wahrscheinlich auch aus diesem grund
herr scholz jeden quadratmeter des
bündnisgebietes zu verteidigen die
osteuropäer haben daran offensichtlich
einen zweifel also noch mal die frage
heißt das für polen und für litauen für
länder wie diese würde deutschland in
den krieg ziehen nur nicht für die
ukraine wir haben sind in der nato
miteinander verbündet und dazu gehört
eine wechselseitige beistandspflicht zu
der wir uns voll umfänglich bekennen das
habe ich im deutschen bundestag noch
einmal klar ausgesprochen und das gehört
auch dazu so wie wir darauf rechnen dass
andere sich einsetzen wenn wir bedroht
sind können die anderen darauf rechnen
dass wir das tun wenn sie bedroht sind
und ich habe den eindruck dass über
diese frage niemand einen zweifel hat
nämlich dass deutschland das tun würde
als teil der nato und dass das auch dazu
beiträgt dass wir im übrigen ja doch
sehr geschlossen handeln seit langer
zeit die entscheidungen die in europa
getroffen worden sind die entscheidung
die nato getroffen hat die entscheidung
die wir mit anderen zusammen
festgelegt haben sind immer
einvernehmlich gelungen und das ist ein
zeichen von einheit und geschlossenheit
mit dem wahrscheinlich die russische
regierung nicht gerechnet im falle der
deutschen bundeswehr also wir
verteidigen das nato gebiet und
verteidigen die länder die in der nato
sind wie ginge das ist die nächste große
frage ist diese deutsche bundeswehr
momentan überhaupt kriegs fähig manche
stellen das in frage weil sie einfach
systematisch kaputtgespart wurde und
jetzt wandern herr scholz 100 milliarden
euro wie sie am sonntag verkündeten und
am samstag offensichtlich beschlossen
haben wandern jetzt in einen löchrigen
eimer und helfen wann
erstens gefällt mir nicht wenn wir das
wort krieg so leichtfertig in den mund
nehmen das möchte ich doch an dieser
stelle betonen es geht um
verteidigungsbereitschaft wir sind kein
kriegsbündnis und ein
verteidigungsbündnis wir wollen keine
anderen länder bedrohen die würden
zeigen dass auch nicht von dir gefällt
damit dass ganz klar ist es geht um
verteidigung und die
verteidigungsfähigkeit notwendig damit
es niemals zu einem krieg kommt das
finde ich muss auch in dieser sendung
klar gesagt werden da sind mir manche
portalen die ich manchmal so lese und
höre etwas locker dass damit nicht so
einer ernsthaften sache darf man nicht
locker sprechen und deshalb zurück zu
dem thema bundeswehr
das ist die größte
verteidigungs einheit kontinentaleuropas
die bundeswehr setzt über 50 ml für die
bundeswehr werden nach berechnung von 50
milliarden euro von deutschland
eingesetzt das ist der größte betrag und
beitrag der dort geleistet die
bundeswehr ist weltweit mit ihrer
einsatzfähigkeit sehr geschätzt und hat
auch wirklich viele viele aufgaben
übernommen in den letzten jahren und tut
das auch jetzt und deshalb finde ich
gerade wenn man darüber redet was jetzt
besser werden muss dass man die
großartige und ja immer auch wieder sehr
gefährliche arbeit der soldaten soldaten
unseres landes nicht so schlecht treten
darf das ist eine hochleistungsfähige
sehr vorbildliche
verteidigungsarmee als und gleichzeitig
ist sozusagen sich seit vielen vielen
jahren darüber dass sie so schlecht
ausgestattet sind und dass man ihnen
jetzt erstmal westen kaufte für den
winter und ordentliche show das tat
zuletzt der chef der bundeswehr bei uns
in der sendung der vermeintliche
investitionsbedarf bei der armee
resultiert aus missmanagement und
fehlplanung nicht aus fehlendem budget
das sagt ihnen die grüne jugend hat sie
recht
erstmal wiederhole ich was ich eben
gesagt habe auch wenn man solche
missstände was bestimmte fragen ist
material in die ferien clark schreiber
die nicht darf man nicht so tun als ob
das jetzt insgesamt nicht eine sehr
leistungsfähige armee wäre die weltweit
hoch anerkannt ist und das ist auch
nicht gut für diejenigen die dort ihre
arbeit tun ich wiederhole mich aber mit
absicht und
trotzdem ist es notwendig etwas zu
machen darum ja sage ich neben dem
ohnehin schon sehr hohen etat der für
die nato über 50 milliarden euro
meldet ist es so dass wir weiteres tun
müssen und dann machen wir ein
einmaliges sondervermögen mit 100
milliarden euro das uns in die lage
versetzt jetzt einmal vernünftig alles
das was wir in den nächsten jahren und
da gibt es ja oft auch um jahrzehnte
brauchen auf den weg zu bringen viele
vorhaben genau zu betrachten ob sie
nötig sind und welche neuen nötig werden
das richtig zu priorisieren sich von
keiner hektik leisten zu lassen sondern
großer ruhe sehr langfristige
strategische entscheidungen zu treffen
die dazu führen dass wir schnell die
leistungsfähigkeit unserer bundeswehr
weiter erhöhen und gleichzeitig
langfristig dafür sorgen dass sie die
größte richtigen ausrüstungsgegenstände
hat damit sie erfolgreich sein kann in
einer ja auch immer technischer
werdenden welt auch in dem bereich der
verteilt die wunschliste von andré
wüstner ist glaube ich sehr lang und die
ist auch entsprechend schon angekommen
bei frau lamprecht 100 milliarden ist
eine stange geld ist es richtig stolz
dass die fraktionsspitzen von bündnis
90/die grünen und von der spd er ist im
grunde kurz vor dieser rede von ihnen in
kenntnis gesetzt worden ich habe mich
mit allen sehr sorgfältig über die tage
hinweg ins benehmen gesetzt das heißt
das ja ganz nett mir ja weil es ja ganz
klar ist dass wir in einer solchen
situation und nach einem solchen
kriegsbeginn gegen ein anderes land in
europa russland gegen die ukraine nicht
einfach
probleme ungelöst lassen können so dass
wir mehr geld für die bundeswehr
bereitstellen müssen und ich habe über
den weg gesprochen in verschiedenen
konstellationen und am ende eine
entscheidung getroffen zu der ich an
amtseid geleistet habe als bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland es ist
meine aufgabe zu sagen welchen weg die
regierung geben will und das habe ich
gemacht freiheit demokratie und
wohlstand sichern auch darauf machten
sie aufmerksam abstriche kann man da
jetzt in anführungsstrichen nur noch
beim wohlstand machen wofür wird geld
fehlen herr scholz sie brauchen eine
stange geld um energiepreise zu sichern
und zu halten um die bundeswehr
auszustatten um alle anderen
wirtschaftlichen probleme abzufedern
wird muss sich die deutsche bevölkerung
auf ein leben nicht mehr in diesem
wohlstand einrichten müssen wir bilden
ein sondervermögen einmalig das jetzt
möglich macht das die bundeswehr sehr
langfristig planen kann das
verteidigungsministeriums haben
langfristig planen kann und wir uns
gemeinsam mit dem parlament sehr
langfristig festlegen können welche
vorhaben wir auf den weg bringen wollen
denn das gehört ja übrigens auch zur
wirklichkeit der beschaffung von
verteidigungssystemen dazu dass die oft
in einigen jahren sehr teuer sind
nämlich wenn sie fertig gestellt sind
und kommt und den anderen jahren nur
entwicklungskosten zu finanzieren
sondern dieses auf und ab und sind
wieder mehr wer das nicht brauchen sagen
sie und deshalb haben wir gesagt wir
werden diese 100 milliarden für die
nächsten jahre zu sind dahin die sind
auch notwendig und die werden über das
sondervermögen zusätzlich als kredit
aufgenommen und das bedeutet aber
umgekehrt auch dass wir all die vorhaben
die wir für ein
besseres zusammenleben in deutschland
für den fortschritt für mehr
gerechtigkeit in der welt den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben für
mehr bildung dass wir alle diese
vorhaben gleichwohl verfolgen können und
auch wollen also das was wir uns gesagt
haben was wir machen wollen für ein
stabiles rentenniveau was wir uns
vorgenommen haben für eine bessere
absicherung von kindern was wir uns
vorgenommen haben für mehr
bildungsgerechtigkeit was wir uns
vorgenommen haben für die mieterinnen
und mietern was wir uns vorgenommen
haben für ein besseres pflege sehen was
wir uns vorgenommen haben im hinblick
auf die große
ökologische transformation unserer
volkswirtschaft so dass wenn sie allein
20 25 jahren co2 neutral wirtschaften
können alles das werden wir mit gleicher
intensität vorantreiben und das
sondervermögen bietet uns die
möglichkeit dass eine zu tun und das
andere nicht untersagt ihre
juso-vorsitzende frau rosenthal sagt wer
will jetzt den pflegenden im
gesundheitswesen erklären dass sie
leider keine unterstützung mehr bekommen
dass weder in die infrastruktur noch in
ihre löhne genug geld geht das müssen am
ende sie machen sie sagen das wird nicht
passieren und wir werden ein besseres
gesundheitssystem haben und die pfleger
werden mehr geld bekommen existiert
genau das ist die absicht die wir als
bundesrat jungen haben das habe ich in
meiner regierungserklärung nach der wahl
zum bundeskanzler so auch festgelegt das
ist das gemeinsame vorhaben der gesamten
koalition und daran werden wir
festhalten
aber wir dürfen ja jetzt gar nicht
zulassen dass es eine solche alternative
gibt entweder das andere eine oder das
andere sondern mit dem weg den ich
vorgeschlagen habe haben wir die
möglichkeit sehr langfristig die
richtigen dinge in allen bereichen der
politik in deutschland voranzubringen
und was ich sehr gut finde ich habe sehr
gute signale bekommen von der größten
oppositionspartei von cdu und csu dass
sie sehr aufgeschlossen sind im hinblick
auf das sondervermögen denn das ist ja
eine gemeinsame anstrengung bleibt die
wertänderung haben nicht nur deshalb das
ist auch in der sache eine gemeinsame
anstrengung die wir in deutschland
fahren müssen wo es gut ist wenn sie
nicht nur auf den schultern der
regierung lastet sondern bin sich
zumindest die größte oppositionspartei
eigentlich weiß mit der regierung das
stimmt ich mache dennoch noch einmal auf
robert habeck aufmerksam und natürlich
reklamiert friedrich merz auch für sich
dass sie jetzt nicht immer nur dafür da
sein können die wohltaten zu verteilen
und die union ihnen die mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag belässt aber dass
man in klammern robert habeck macht
darauf aufmerksam dass die wirtschaft
sich sehr wohl um gucken werden muss
unter diesen neuen bedingungen dass wir
jetzt anfangen die energetische basis
dieses landes zu organisieren für den
nächsten winter und dass das weiter
steigende energiepreise zur folge haben
wird ich frage sie nochmal sie sind
sicher den menschen zu sagen wir werden
keine größeren abstriche machen müssen
wir schaffen das ich habe einmal über
die politischen vorhaben gesprochen
regel haben und ansonsten
macht es überhaupt keinen sinn dass wir
uns irgendwas vormachen hier in
deutschland also wenn es an
ökonomische konfrontation gibt durch die
sanktion hat das folgen sicher für
russland das wird man aber es hat immer
auch folgen für uns wenn wir sehen dass
die preise für energie weltweit
steigenden gas kohle egal wo wir sie
hier beziehen dann wird das sowie unsere
volkswirtschaft heute aufgestellt ist
auch erstmal unmittelbare auswirkungen
haben und daraus muss man mehrere
konsequenzen ziehen konsequenzen
lasst die leute nicht alleine deshalb
haben wir den die absenkung der eeg
umlage die die strompreise belastet
jetzt schon vorgezogen auf die mitte
dieses jahres deshalb sorgen wir dafür
dass es eine heizkostenpauschale gibt
für wohngeldempfänger darum sorgen wir
dafür dass familien die ganz wenig geld
haben etwas mehr geld bekommen dass
kinder besser unterstützt werden weil
ich das haben wir eine woche vor diesen
entscheidungen auf den weg gebracht und
daran halten wir auch fest genau aus
dieser lage heraus denn die höheren
energiepreise waren ja schon vorher da
und gleichzeitig müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass wir unsere abhängigkeiten
reduzieren und zwar schnell und zwar
schnell und wir gucken noch einmal
darauf was das dann schlussendlich auch
politisch bedeutet das heißt dass die
grünen sich jetzt erstmal dafür
aussprechen die kohlekraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen dass sich die fdp dafür
ausspricht auch mehr schulden zu machen
denn das ist diese sondereigentum
und dass auf der anderen seite die
sozialdemokratie sich mit dem gedanken
anfreundet auch rüsten und hochrüsten zu
müssen sie sind für etwas anderes
gewählt wurden herr scholz auch für sie
persönlich aber im grunde alle drei
parteien diese ampel das ist eine bürde
ist diese bürde zu groß für eine ampel
regierung die sie führen ein und die
regierungsparteien die ministerin
minister die
führungskräfte der fraktionen die ganzen
fraktionen die parteien wissen genau was
los ist und deshalb stehen alle hinter
dem konzept dass ich da vorgetragen habe
ich glaube dass das etwas ist das
gemeinsam angepackt werden und es macht
ja gleichwohl möglich die großen
reformvorhaben die wir uns für die
modernisierung unseres landes
vorgenommen haben umzusetzen ich habe es
schon gesagt aber will ist hier noch mal
unterstreichen wir werden die
modernisierungspolitik die politik für
mehr gerechtigkeit in unserer
gesellschaft für die ökologische
transformation nicht aufgeben sondern
forcieren und gleichzeitig ist es so
dass wir eben die aufgabe den schultern
die damit verbunden sind dass die welt
nun gerade auf eine sehr dramatische
weise erheblich und friedlicher geworden
ist und dass wir mit
einer politik die auf frieden
ausgerichtet ist aber auch auf eigene
stärke beruht versuchen müssen genau
diesen frieden zu sichern
olaf scholz bei uns der deutsche
bundeskanzler danke für den besuch hier
heute abend bei uns im studio
die deutschen hat er auf harte zeiten
eingestimmt und gleichzeitig zum
ausdruck bringen wollen dass an den
plänen dieser regierung nur wenig
gerüttelt werden muss danke nochmal für
ihre anwesenheit und ihr reden und bei
markus lanz ist jetzt unter anderem die
bürgerrechtlerin irina scherbakowa zu
gast sie ist eine der mitbegründerinnen
von memorial und wir sehen uns wenn sie
mögen am kommenden donnerstag wieder um
22.15 zur gebundenen zeit kommen sie gut
durch den abend ganz herzlichen dank und
nochmal danke ansehen
[Musik]